happy International Women's Day today's
video is about a project that I did with
an awesome organization called built by
girls built by girls prepares the next
generation of female leaders creators
and builders to boldly step into the
careers powered by technology and for
International Women's Day they're
launching a campaign called this is a
world built by girls and I was lucky
enough to be a part of this campaign
where they flew me out to New York City
to be on set to capture some extra
content the campaign features amazing
honest conversations between tech
leaders and experts and professionals
advisers talking to advisees who are
mostly students who have also made a
name for themselves where they have a
really honest discussion about being a
woman in the workplace and the tech
industry being there in the room with
them in New York City was such a treat
hearing their conversations happen live
I heard so many inspiring and motivating
things that really just gave me so much
energy and so thank you again to built
by girls for flying me out there and I
was there to capture some extra content
and so I really wanted to highlight the
incredible women who were the advisees
for those videos and we played a little
game a little game that I like to call
yes or pass basically I gave these
advisees various topics on being a
student in technology and the tech
industry itself and I asked them to yes
or pass them and explained why I thought
it would be a quick and easy way to get
some honest opinions about being in and
around the tech industry don't forget to
stay around to the end for a preview of
the amazing interviews that these women
have done and without further ado I'll
begin by introducing the advisees and
let's get started hi my name is Tatiana
Alexander and I am a student at the
borough of Manhattan Community College
studying business management and I am
also a data entry specialist at wework
my name is Isabel Porteous and I'm the
built by girls wave advisee I go to high
school in New York City I'm 17
and I'm a junior so my name is Isabel I
am a sophomore at Hunter College I am
majoring in bioinformatics and a
minoring in computer science I am
Christina Saha and I am a junior at
Barnard College studying computer
science yes I am all about conference
fire I love the built by girls stickers
and tote bags and that kind of thing
makes me feel part of a community
I love techs why my good news you know
what's crazy is that like every
networking event I try to get as much so
I guess possible because you know it not
only looks good but it also feels good
to be a part of like that occasion and
you're able to like promote it
everywhere you go so I've had people ask
me about my belt by girl stickers and
I've had people ask me for something I
give them some Yas free stuff is always
great I love t-shirts
I think t-shirts are such a great way to
like wrap something even if you're not a
part of it but you can go around telling
everyone hey look Twitter hashtag
[Music]
so I will I've only recently joined like
the tech field and I've never seen a
more empowering supportive community in
my life like I have received more hugs
here that are not from my family member
is Bentley ever and I just feel like
having people to look up to having like
a tangible human being to aspire to
become is amazing like it would it is
driving me further absolutely yes
I think there's nothing better for a
woman than to see another woman succeed
and being able to communicate with each
other and feed off of each other's
positivity and success can really take
you to levels that you probably never
imagined and that's what woman
solidarity is all about and that's why
we need it so much I feel like they're
absolutely necessary to have even if
you're not a woman yourself I feel like
it's always good to have a woman role
model because you're able to see the
world in a different perspective than
you otherwise wouldn't have seen yes I
mean career fairs are a good place to
learn more about the industry that if
you have an interest in school you can
only pursue it so far in class career
fair is a good opportunity yes um I
think it's a great way to get yourself
out there and talk to more people and
it's literally being handed to you so as
long as you're able to go there with
your resume dress properly and present
the best version of yourself I think
it's getting you're put into the pool
you know before a lot of other people
Pass I know the girls can code I can
code all my friends can code I started
with Lego Mindstorms coding when I was
in third grade and ever since then I've
known that it's something that girls can
be good at and be great at pass huge
pass terrible period
Hey hi hey Butler girls I thought my
girl and a newcomer to the tech world
what a nice you have to so I can show
that I'm just as people achieve these
guys and make sweet tech of such a mouth
I'll mated industry that I think having
a support system within in tech around
you is critical so critical and always
remind ourselves that we make those
rooms better by being present in them
yes you better give us the whole damn
dollar and not a penny less there's
something rockets into space they
themselves have set out loud
diversity is hard and it's so amazing
that you do robotics Wow yeah maybe I
can be a role model for other girls who
want to go into tech because it can be
scary to not have somebody to look up to
or to see somebody else doing it let's
do better this is what a leader looks
like I belong here
and I'm carving out my space
awesome well thank you so much for
watching I hope you liked that video
thank you so much again to built by
girls for letting me be a part of this
campaign being able to go to New York
was incredible in meeting the team who
is behind built by girls they are just
such kind passionate warm amazing women
who are doing something really great and
I got again I got so much energy from
this two or three days in New York that
I am so fortunate to be in this world
and to have these opportunities so thank
you so much again and as always don't
forget to like this video
especially if you'd like to learn more
about organizations and communities like
this one that lifts up people to be a
part of the tech industry and don't
forget to smash the subscribe button and
the notification belt to get notified
for my new videos all right well thank
you so much for being here and thank you
for sticking around to the end I will
see you next time bye well I honestly
love both my girls because that was like
my first mark in the tech industry and
that was where I found you know myself
and was able to identify myself as a
woman in tech from the team to the
community that they have built around
themselves is amazing literally like
it's the most wonderful you know
community of women